Chris waters here with a gamespot news
update despite an early sales lead by
the PlayStation 4 Microsoft isn't out of
it yet the head of Xbox Phil Spencer has
tweeted at a fan that Microsoft is
definitely in it to win it I laying all
fears that they were like gonna settle
for second place or something like that
Phil Spencer the recently announced head
of Xbox overseas Xbox and Xbox Live as
well as the creative teams at Microsoft
Studios after telling a fan that he was
more excited than nervous for e3 he went
on to say that quote we need to do more
that's one hundred percent of my focus
Xbox one originally touted as an
all-in-one entertainment system has been
more recently focusing their energies on
the core gamer in response to a fan
telling Microsoft to bring the hype to
e3 Spencer wrote bringing more than hype
we're bringing games Sony's PlayStation
4 has maintained the lead in console
sales in the US for the last three
months according to the NPD despite the
xbox pc exclusive titanfall being the
best selling game of march III 2014 is
going to be a huge deal for Microsoft
and Sony as they got to show us the
games now that the consoles are out
gamespot is going to be there on the
show floor live bringing you all sorts
of game announcements and demos so be
sure to 2 in in two months a tree
you